this film is um
made for my patreon
site
and
in time i may release it to the general
public
but it's something that i've kept really
from the first time i met psychosensi
this is to celebrate my 200th film
to give
my patrons
the first chance of
trying this out
it may
allude you for the rest of your life you
may never ever
find it
well my first meeting
when i went to new zealand
to meet cited scentsy
uh and this film will be in two sections
because uh
what i want to tell you
i went all the way to new zealand
to see saito scentsy for the first time
he heard that
an english person had come all the way
around the world
and he was highly delighted and that
evening
he sent somebody to collect me
uh from my accommodation
because he wanted
for me to be there with his uchidesis
that he bought from iwama
the gentleman whose house he was staying
in keith hartley
and there was just
me inside of sanji sitting
and at that point
the most i ever drank was
orange juice and lemonade
but
he said that i had to pour him a vodka
so i poured him a vodka
he
got a glass and poured one back and i
said so essentially i don't drink
um he was very insistent upon me
drinking
so it was my first taste of vodka
i can't remember what age i was
now
but 1983
i was born in 1950 so you can work it
out 33 is that i was a second dan
and
i wasn't interested in alcohol
but
he kept talking and of course i couldn't
understand japanese he couldn't
understand english
but the vodka was going down
and eventually to save us
the
hamburgers and all the meat and the
barbecue being cooked by keith hartley
and
the uchidashi andre from switzerland
arrived and
as i arrived it was ready for eating
so so we had this uh
very nice barbecue
of course me never been drunk drinking
before alcohol didn't take a lot to get
me
drunk i don't remember eating the food
bob see i i did eat it
so
my mind stayed clouded about this
but i think most of you listening to me
will know that
in circumstance in circum certain
circumstances
a person can sober up very quickly if
it's in a shock situation
well after eating the barbecue and there
was i don't know what keith was doing
but there was just me and
me and andre
the psycho sensei he
he got this belt
normal key belt
throw over one shoulder come over the
other shoulder
and
before you knew what happened it was
like a he'd strapped a pair of braces to
him
and he said oh we used to do this when i
was a young boy and we would grip the
braces and
like judo play wrestle
now
i'm five ten and a half in feet in
inches
andre i'm gonna guess must be
six two six feet two inches
he's a really
tall big guy
and he'd been uchidashi for one year he
was a showdown
very powerful i couldn't believe how
powerful he was i mean i was a new dan
he was a showdown
and
i didn't even feel
first q quality
against him or some of the students
out there
it was that powerful the difference
anyhow
cytosensei
he stands against the wall with these
braces on this belt
and he told me to grip him up top and
pin
in his indents
he actually told us where to pin him
for the best position for us and the
worst position for him
i mean how many teachers really would
do that
most would
want you to have the easiest position
to escape from rather than tell the
eucharist that this is the best place
you can be to really get me
and he then laughed and joked
i can't remember and it was but he would
have been somewhere on the straps
he told us to push hard and he joked
that we were not pushing hard enough
so he said i said push
translated
that
andre quickly says put your hannah
on that second push
it was as if
cypher sensei instructed
an atemi
by his word saying
push harder
and that was taking our mind just for a
split second
so as we push
harder this is when
i realized that i so grew up
served up
my nose and andre's nose was hard
pressed against the wall and cytoscencey
was behind
both of us
again laughing
but the power that not only did the
escapers escape with but
somehow
arms had collapsed
our noses were against the wall
i asked such a sensi
sensei how did you do that
how did you do it you know we didn't
even know
now perhaps it was because i'd had too
much to drink i didn't know
but i remember asking andre he came to
england in the inside of since he sent
him to england to teach me
i asked andre in the end
because he hadn't been drinking he'd
been outside doing barbecue
i said how did sensei do that and he
said i don't know
how did he escape
get behind us
and press us with his power against the
wall
at the time our cytosensing
through andre again translating
sentencing how did you do that
he said
i went when you pushed harder you pushed
me through the wall
i went through the wall in the bedroom
come out of the bedroom door
through the hall
and that way i was behind you
and i then pushed you on the wall
and again laughed his head off wonderful
thing about psychosexy was he did like a
good joke and a good laugh
and if he was in the right mood he would
tell you
everything about him and those scentsy
and i've got so many stories to tell
that
is the first part of this film
for the next i don't know
20 30 years i i don't know how long it
is
but i wondered how he'd done it
and i and i'm going to tell you
in the next film
how i've achieved to do it
not that technique but i've
managed to understand
what we have to do
to be able to
escape
and escape something that seems an
impossibility to escape
but not only escape
but to escape with ease and freedom and
not the thought of as many of you will
know
sometimes we escaped and even go
i didn't know i was going to actually
get out of that
so the second part of this film
will be
giving you the answer
but you may have to search it
for as long as i did
20 30 years or however long it took
until you get the answer
and i think then
you find the essence not only of aikido
but of your true self
thank you for listening
part two
will be
followed shortly